as elon musk often says space travel is
something that people
all around the world can get excited
about as it's not just individual
countries winning
but rather the entirety of humanity from
establishing a base on the moon and mars
to eventually venturing out of the solar
system
it's no doubt that space travel is the
future long term
but despite this currently space isn't
the most
profitable businesses as the space
market is really just limited to
governments
and companies launching various
satellites however
as space travel becomes accessible to
the average customer
it's only a matter of time until
spacex's valuation
launches for the stars but when it does
how high can they get
well starting off looking into the next
30 years
the two main businesses for spacex would
be starlink
and starship near the end of this video
we'll discuss the potential of asteroid
mining
but first taking a look at starlink this
project
is supposed to make high-speed internet
available to rural
and remote places using satellite
internet the vast majority of rural
and remote places are neglected by the
big internet providers like att
and spectrum because it simply doesn't
make economical sense for them to set up
the necessary infrastructure
to support a relatively small group of
people this
is especially true for technological
advancements such as fiber optic cables
the thing is it makes sense for a t to
install fiber optic cables in a large
city
to potentially win over some market
share however
what's the point of installing fireball
uptake in the middle of nebraska
where they already have 100 market share
and
this is where starlink makes its entry
unlike traditional internet providers
spacex doesn't have to build
infrastructure specific to each
community
instead they can simply launch a bunch
of satellites which can serve people
both in the centers of new york and
london
as well as people in the amazon
rainforest and sahara desert
traditional infrastructure costs can
only be spread amongst a given
community's population
however spacex's satellite costs can be
spread amongst their entire customer
base
and this is the root of their profit so
that's the market for starlink and why
they don't really need to fight head-on
with any providers to win over this
market
with that being said how many people
will actually use this
well just recently spacex requested
permission from the us
to deploy 5 million user terminals which
is up from the original request of 1
million
and that's just for users within the us
the us only has about a 20th of the
world population
so this should scale up to 100 million
customers globally
but of course not all countries have the
same purchasing power as the us
and starlink may not be available in
many countries
so we'll say that global demand is just
a quarter of that
at 25 million during the early stages of
starlink or basically the next decade
now i'm sure that with a good speeds
latency and prices
spacex could capture hundreds of
millions of customers
within the next few decades but i don't
really think they care to do this
starlink is more of a hey let's fund
mars by helping people who are getting
screwed over
by their internet providers as opposed
to hey
let's become the most dominant broadband
service in the world
so i doubt they'll be too aggressive
when expanding
especially after other projects become
more viable
thus we'll say that they stabilize at
about double their initial demand
which would put them at about 50 million
worldwide customers
and we can reasonably expect this to
occur within the next 20 years
as for the pricing of startling services
the expected price is 80
a month and the average sale price will
likely be upwards of one hundred dollars
a month
but we'll call it 80 to estimate
conservatively with
50 million subscribers at 80 a month we
get 4 billion in revenue per month
or about 50 billion in revenue per year
to put this in perspective
at t pulls in between 170 and 180
billion
annually off of just the u.s market
currently
the global broadband service market is
worth 326.7 billion dollars
but this is expected to grow 9 per year
up until 2027
which would increase the market to 597
billion dollars
so by the time starlink gets the 50
billion dollars in revenue annually
they'll control about five to ten
percent of the global market
which is definitely a solid portion but
nothing dominant
as for their profit from starlink well
satellite internet providers today
aren't exactly profitable for instance
taking a look at vsat who is a
nationwide satellite internet provider
they're essentially breaking even
they've had some positive years and some
negative years
but most of their profits and losses are
well below
one percent of their annual revenue for
instance
over the past 12 months they've lost 1
million dollars
which is nothing for a company pulling
in over 2 billion
in revenue annually moreover their gross
profit has been consistently increasing
so their lack of profitability seems to
be a result of expansion
as opposed to a bad business model thus
giving starlink a very reasonable net
profit margin of just
three percent they would still pull in
about 1.5 billion dollars per year
that's nearly their entire current
annual revenue so
this would definitely give them a lot of
room to invest
and advance their various technologies
speaking of new technology
their next big project that will bring
in massive revenue and profit
is of course starship starship is
primarily being developed
to enable interplanetary travel
specifically to mars
but let's be real here how many people
will not only want to visit
but also be able to pay half a million
dollars to visit mars
now don't get me wrong here getting
people to mars will likely be one of the
biggest achievements in human history
but from a business perspective it's
really not going to make that much money
at least not in the next few decades the
real monetary potential for starship
is with intraplanetary travel or travel
within the earth spacex is planned to
use starship to provide super fast
travel
within the earth for journeys like
houston to dubai
and dubai to sydney as most long
distance trips can be completed with
starship
in less than 30 minutes so for most
travelers
it would be a no-brainer to use starship
for long distance travel
as opposed to regular airliners as it
would save several hours each way
really the only barriers for starship
are price and safety
which are of course very serious issues
right now spacex is still planning to
use starship to get to mars in 2024
i'm not quite sure that that time frame
will quite work out
but i do think they'll have starship
ready to go within the next 5 to 10
years
but that doesn't mean that it'll be
accessible to the average person by 2030
starship will no doubt have to jump
through many hoops to prove its
long-term safety
and win over government approval for
consumer use
as a result it will likely take five to
ten years of cargo missions
and limited human testing before
governments allow starship to fly over
land
and take customers on a regular basis
and such
so we're likely looking at 2040 before
starship
really goes mainstream and starts to eat
up market share from the airlines
but once this process begins there's no
stopping it
and here's why starship prices will be
significantly higher than airlines
but they're not too bad spacex
hopes to achieve a pro launch cost of 2
million
and that's the mars where both starship
and the super heavy booster will need to
be fueled up
for intraplanetary travel only a
starship
or the top part of a rocket is expected
to be used
which in the words of elon musk
dramatically improves cost
complexity and the ease of operations
this is quite obvious as you're only
using half the rocket
so point to point travel will likely
have a per launch cost
closer to 1 million dollars but we'll
say that this is super ambitious
and that mars launches end up costing 4
million in 2040.
that would make point-to-point launches
about 2 million
we also have expenses other than the
launch itself
for instance they'll have to pay a
ground crew inspectors between flights
maybe buy some licenses you get the
point we'll say that external costs
add up to half a million dollars per
launch throw in another half million for
profit or a 16.6
margin and we have a pre-launch cost of
about 3 million dollars
the good part is that this is spread
over 1 000 passengers
which comes out to a per passenger price
of 3 000.
over time though this cost is simply
going to go down
as spacex increases efficiency so we'll
likely see a price in the two to three
thousand dollar range
in the first five to ten years of the
service and
that makes sense as gwen shotwell who is
a chief operating officer of spacex
has stated that earth-to-earth tickets
will cost between economy
and business-class flight tickets
currently a one-way flight ticket from
new york to dubai
cost a little over 800 bucks for
emirates upgrading that ticket to
business class will take that price
up to forty five hundred dollars first
class on the other hand
will push up to fourteen thousand five
hundred dollars
but that's irrelevant to our calculation
anyways
something else to keep in mind is that
these ticket prices
are with pandemic savings so on a
regular day
we're likely looking at upwards of one
thousand dollars for economy
and upwards of five thousand dollars for
business as a result
starship lands right in the middle so
yes
starship will cost 2-3 times more than
the regular flight ticket
at least at the start but i don't think
this is nearly as big of a problem
as it might seem you have to keep in
mind that starship
provides exponential value yes it's two
to three times the price
but it also shortens a 14 hour flight to
half an hour
or 28 times faster and people who travel
internationally
aren't generally broke they can afford
to buy business class if they wanted to
but they don't think it's worth the
price in other words
we generally don't want to throw several
thousand dollars down the drain
with some extra leg room and a larger tv
heck
even after bill gates became a
multi-billionaire he would travel in the
economy
until of course he got his own jet thus
the logic of flying economy
isn't usually i can't afford business
but rather
why pay more to travel on the same plane
however
when we are shown exponential value we
are always ready to pay more
and this has been proven time and time
again throughout history
for instance third class tickets on the
titanic started at 15
which is the same as 107 today and the
titanic was a 137 hour voyage
today a one-way flight ticket from
london to new york
cost a minimum of 285 dollars with no
stops
and that's again with the pandemic
savings
usually such a ticket would cost well
into the 300s
or about double the price of the titanic
thus people were willing to spend two
times the price
to reduce travel time exponentially
aside from that
people have been very willing to spend
money on advanced technology
the iphone was 10 times the price of the
average phone when it came out
but given exponential advantages apple
has sold 2.2 billion phones since launch
similarly when did dropping tens of
thousands on a car become normal
and when did spending thousands of
dollars on computers become
ordinary evidently people adopt new
technology
even when it's 5 to 10 times more
expensive if the value is large enough
thus as long as people feel safe we'll
see a significant proportion of
all long distance travelers switch to
starship not just business travelers
especially when it's only two to three
times the cost which many will be
willing to pay
with all that being said in 2018
global airline revenue was 824 billion
dollars
and it was growing at 9.4 percent per
year
of course we're seeing an artificial
pullback right now
but things will likely go back to normal
by 2022.
so assuming 824 billion dollars in
revenue in 2022
and 9.4 growth per year starting then
we would see 4.151 trillion dollars in
global airline revenue by 2040.
assuming growth slows down in the 2030s
we'll still see about 3 trillion
in revenue by 2040 or about triple what
we have now
and this is in line with many
projections of increased demand
over the next few decades in 2019
we had 4.7 billion global airline
passengers
the aci or airport's council
international
expects that traffic will reach 19.7
billion
by 2040 or over four times more than
today
as for what proportion of these flights
are long-haul flights
we don't have access to international
data however
the united kingdom has released its data
in 2020
without a pandemic they expected to have
upwards of 100 million long-haul flights
and upwards of 200 million short-haul
flights so
for them about one third of their
flights are long-haul flights
but something to keep in mind is that
though only one-third of these flights
are long-haul flights
these one-third of flights account for
much more than one-third of airline
revenue
as long-haul flight tickets simply cost
significantly more
as a result long-haul flights likely
account for 40 to 50 percent of airline
revenue
or about 1.2 to 1.5 trillion dollars in
annual revenue by 2040 as for what
proportion of these passengers will
switch over to starship
well business and first class bookings
account for about 11
of flight tickets and the vast majority
of this crowd
will switch over to starship as they're
already paying for airline fares that
well exceed the cost of a starship
ticket
and saving time is very important
especially because they travel
on a regular basis thus assuming that 90
of these travelers will switch over to
starship by 2050
that would allow spacex to capture 10
percent of the long-haul market
as for the 89 of economy customers we'll
assume that about a third of them are
willing to pay more to save time
thus giving starship 40 of the long haul
market by
2050 at this rate spacex would pull in
passengers who were paying 500 billion
dollars per year
but we have to keep in mind that for the
majority of these passengers
spacex tickets cost two to three times
more than their previous tickets
so spacex would actually be pulling in
revenue
between one and one and a half trillion
dollars annually
airlines typically have net profit
margins of about 10 percent
but spacex is offering a premium service
for a premium price
not to mention that they will likely
have no competition
at least at the beginning thus with one
trillion dollars in revenue and a net
profit margin of 15
spacex would profit 150 billion dollars
annually as you can see starship will
dwarf profit from star link
and that brings us into the final source
of revenue for spacex
which is asteroid mining but there's
one major flaw with this plan elon musk
doesn't think that space mining will be
profitable and he has made this clear
several times
he simply thinks that the cost of
transport will outweigh the cost of this
mining on earth
moreover an influx of precious metals
such as gold and silver
would likely lead to a drop in value due
to greater supply
so unfortunately it doesn't look like
elon
wants to get spacex into the asteroid
mining business
anytime soon but aside from asteroid
mining
not being profitable i think that the
main reason elon doesn't want to get
into space mining business
is because he doesn't find it to be a
problem
though elon musk has made tens of
billions from his various companies
at heart he's an engineer and though he
agrees that spacex needs to make money
to make progress
money isn't really the goal for him but
rather solving problems
starlink provides internet to remote and
rural areas
and starship enables exponentially
faster interplanetary travel
as well as interplanetary travel but
what does space mining accomplish give
people more jewelry
if the earth desperately needed more
precious metals to move society forward
in some manner i'm sure he'd focus on
space mining
but as this is currently not the case i
think he'll stick to lowering the cost
of space travel
and exploration in the meantime spacex
is
already profiting 150 billion annually
from starlink and starship and will call
all of their profit from moon and mars
launches and
everything else to be our margin of
error so as for the company's valuation
elon musk has suggested that he'll keep
the company private for the time being
to avoid market volatility however we
may very well see an ipo
after spacex has achieved regular
flights to mars
at which point they will be a much more
stable company
as for their pu ratio or the ratio
between early net profit and market
valuation
spacex is likely to have a sky-high p e
ratio due to its future on mars and
possibly
other plants as well thus expecting a p
e ratio of a hundred
is not really that far off given that
amazon has a pu ratio of
127 and a tesla has a p e ratio of over
a
thousand with a p e ratio of 100
space x would be worth 15 trillion
dollars
but even with a more grounded pe ratio
in the 30s like most popular tech
companies
spacex would be worth 5 trillion thus
spacex will likely be worth about 10
trillion dollars by the end of 2050
after executing starlink and
point-to-point travel using starship
by 2100 though who knows where spacex
will be
as thereby history how high do you guys
think spacex can get by the end of the
century
comment that down below and of course
drop a like if you guys appreciate the
depth
of this video and consider subscribing
to see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one